it was reported this week that Hollywood
is making a movie about Roger Ailes of
course he was the controversial Fox News
chairman who built the network into a
conservative media powerhouse so they're
making a Roger Ailes movie they had just
announced that Charlize Theron is gonna
play former Fox News anchor megyn kelly
this is a big news yes yes right yeah
now the rest of the casting list is top
secret no one knows what it is I managed
to get my hands on it cuz I'm kind of a
big deal in the industry don't laugh of
that anyway you guys want to see the
cast unless this is real you wanna go
first up first up Fox and Friends
co-host Steve Doocy is gonna be played
by Ed Begley Jr I think that's actually
a pretty good choice news anchor Shepard
Smith will be played by Gary Sinise
again that seems to make sense
top show host Laura Ingraham is gonna be
played by Owen Wilson
and see that one coming Fox News
contributor Tommy Lauren will be played
by this box of hair dye yeah it really
is just just the Box Greta Van Susteren
will be played by country singer Keith
Urban now I feel strange choice Tucker
Carlson Tucker Carlson's in it yeah he's
gonna be played by this stock photo of a
guy with indigestion Sara Huckabee
Sanders will be played by the lady
calling the cops because black people
are barbecuing gretchen carlson gretchen
carlson will be played by melon cat
Kellyanne Conway Kellyanne Conway will
be played by Mick Jagger I'm excited
about Rupert Murdoch Rupert Murdoch will
be played by this tug sticking his head
out of a speeding car
Sean Hannity will be played by this
blow-up doll right here Roger Ailes
himself will be played by this blobfish
they found it former Fox contributor
Rudy Giuliani will be played by this
llama and and as always President Donald
Trump will be played by a bullfrog with
a red wig so look ordered a good show
for movie whatever it is
you